[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parle sport l'émission ne surtout pas
manquer si vous êtes un amoureux de
sport local aujourd'hui il y aura comme
toujours des analyses techniques des
décryptages et surtout une se de bonne
humeur pour m'accompagner nos
chroniqueurs sont avec nous sur ce
plateau et ils sont en pleine forme
comme toujours présentation en musique
on commence à ma droite musique c'est un
véritable guerrier un guerrier très
élégant un mélange entre George Clounet
et Russel crro on a l'habitude de le
voir déambuler dans les rues de
Versailles avec sa peau de bête quand
les températures se rafraîchissent notre
gladiateur Pierre Chevalier du Rugby
Club de versaill est avec nous for et
bonheur salut Michel salut à tous
comment allez-vous fort bien j'ai laissé
la peau de bête dehors oui les
températures se rafraîchissent ell se
rafraîchissent donc là donc là je
l'utilise à plein mais elles st un petit
peu le poney donc il faut que il faut
que je la laisse dehors d'accord ok mais
chaud chaud dedans et froid dehors voilà
donc c'est très bien très bien on on est
très heureux en tout cas de vous avoir
sur cette émission à nouveau on continue
à gauche musique vous connaissez sa
musique c'est un Italien un vrai il nous
vient tout droit du petit mais
magnifique village de Diamante dans le
sud de l'Italie il mange italien il vit
italien regarde des émissions italiennes
mais il est aussi très fort sur
l'actualité des iin notre italien lover
greégoryi canadané est avec nous pendant
1 heure bonsoir Michel bonsoir PIR
bonsoir à tous vous vivez italien je vis
italien et d'ailleurs le sport italien
m'a donné quelques belles heures
dernièrement puisque l'Italie a gagné la
coupe DESV Bagaya nouveau champion du
monde de Moto GP et grand soulagement
parce que l'Italie sera bien à l'euro
2024 de football même si elle est dans
un groupe très difficile oui je vous
pouvez nous préciser le groupe peut-être
Espagne Croatie et Albanie a priori
l'Albanie c'est l'adversaire le plus à
la portée des Italiens on va retenir que
dans cette euro il y a aussi
potentiellement les trois meilleurs
enfin les troisè meilleurs classés voilà
qui pourront accéder en 8e de final donc
pourquoi pas pour l'Italie en tant que
meilleur 3è on croise les doigts pour
pour l'Italie on espère un match
Italie-France peut-être en finale de
l'Euro pourquoi pas on passe de l'autre
côté à musique il est aujourd'hui un
titulaire indiscutable lui aussi aime
sortir la peau de bête quand les temp
ure commence tout doucement à se
rafraîchir en décembre très
professionnel il donnera j'en suis sûr
le meilleur de lui-même Philippe volac
responsable sponsoring chez Orange en
île-defance est avec nous pendant une
heure bonjour tout le monde comment
allez-vous Philippe bah très bien je me
suis ressourcer un weekend prolongé en
Bretagne donc ça m'a fait du bien il
faisait aussi froid qu'ici mais voilà
vous partagez la peau de bête avec
Pierre peut-être c'est ça c'est ça on
l'a partagé je lui ai rendu on a recousu
et
pu on n pas le en termine de l'autre
côté musique mesdames et messieurs nous
avons une légende sur ce plateau une
légende vivante le type de personnalité
que l'on croise seulement une à deux
fois dans sa vie ces analyses sont
toujours précises ces punchline traverse
les écrans de télévision jeanm
ex-entraîneur de plaisir est avec nous
pendant une heure bonsoir Michell
bonsoir à tous sal comment allez-vous
super fort on est content de vous avoir
sur ce plateau parce que vous n'étiez
pas là la dernière fois non non non je
petit imp pass ça vite fait mais ça y
est revenêt pleine forme pleine forme
pleine formepréattaquer tout tout
biené c'est les sujets voilà ouais vous
avez travaillé les sujets
à
fond alors avant de passer au programme
au programme de l'émission on va parler
football et de la Coupe du Monde U17 qui
s'est terminé par une défaite de
l'équipe de France au tir au but contre
l'Allemagne alors que le score était de
deux partout trois joueurs originaires
des Evelin faisaent partie de ce groupe
France il s'agit de tidam Gomis Johan
et Yoram zag les deux premiers ont pris
part à cette finale Tam Gomis était
titulaire et Johan tinkr était est entré
à la 90e minute tidam l'ancien
pensionnaire de boiflefin a fait une
passe décisive mais il a raté un tir au
but une belle compétition quand même
pour nos trois ivelinois la question sur
cette thématique l'avenir s'annonce--il
radieux pour ces pépites zvelinoises oui
ou non vous votez partagez ouais
partagezêes ouais alors pourquoi Gregory
bah parce que briller dans une
compétition de jeunes U17 n'est
malheureusement pas gage de réussite il
y a un gap qui est énorme entre le
football pour les jeunes et le football
professionnel alors il y en a qui ont
déjà signé des contrats professionnel
c'est le cas de Yoram zag et de tidam
Gomis qui évolue en Ligue 2 qui est
peut-être le plus expérimenté des trois
puisque lui a des matchs vraiment
professionnels à son actif mais on a vu
par le passé des jeunes qui ont brillé
avec l'équipe de France de jeune je
pense à un Anthony le Talek par exemple
qui a une belle carrière de footeux on
va dire en Ligue 1 mais il a pas non
plus on va dire il n'a pas répondu aux
attentes qu'on lui qu'on lui prêtait
donc Brill en jeune n'est pas forcément
gage de réussite par contre oui c'està-
direire que les voyants sont auverts
parce que ils sont allés jusqu'en finale
de cette coupe du monde ils débutent
bien leur carrière ils sont mis en
lumière aussi pour pour des clubs
professionnels devant des des clubs
professionnels donc on va dire que les
voyants sont sont au vert mais ce n'est
pas quand même gage de réussite il leur
reste encore un un gros chemin à
accomplir oui je précise qu'il y a 22
ans les Français avaient remporté ce
titre il y avait Anthony le Talec
Florent sininama Pongol ou encore
mourade megni qui faisait partie de
cette équipe de France championne du
monde Pierre Chevalier vous étiez
partagé ouais partager parce que c'est
c'est c'est très difficile sur sur une
campagne comme celle-là même s'il y a
même s'il y a plusieurs matchs pour pour
les voir vrai et sur et sur la finale et
sur la finale aussi de de de leur
accorder du temps de jeu et voir voir en
gros effectivement s'ils sont s'ils sont
bien en bien en pleine bour et en pleine
possession de leur moyens en équipe de
France je les ai pas vu jouer en club et
donc l'avenir nous le dira là c'est
juste un petit peu un petit peu tôt pour
pouvoir dire que que la trajectoire est
est toute tracée ce qu'il faut noter
c'est quand même en U 17 malgré tout ils
sont en équipe de France donc en
sélection c'est déjà c'est déjà un signe
très encourageant pour le le talent de
ces de ces trois pépites vinoises Philip
volac ouais en fin ces deux finales qui
perdent dans une année déjà contre
l'Allemagne au mois de juin à l'euro au
penalty aussi au tir au but aussi ou on
a l'habitude de perdre au TI but en
général en France fait ou voilà bon ce
qu'il faut se dire aussi c'est que dans
les moins de 17 enfin il manquait quand
même des deux joueurs dujà du PSG etan
Mbappé un autre aussi manquait aussi ben
Zir Emry aussi qui aurait pu être là
aussi s'ils avait un autre joueur s'ils
avaient été là ça aurait haussé le
niveau aussi et ils auraient pu battre
l'Allemagne mais bon c'est dommage quand
même de perdre deux fois contre
l'Allemagne l'Allemagne c'est la
première je crois que c'est la première
fois que qu'une équipe dans la même
année est championne d'Europe championne
du monde et bon ça c'est pas joué à
grand chose ils ont raté leur première
mi-temps et ils sont revenus mais bien
trop tard et puis au penalty ils avaient
la ils avaient la main de gagner au au
au penalty ils ont eu l'occasion et
voilà la la qui gagne voilà ça rappelle
des
souvenir du bal comp
l'orchestre alors moi ce que j'en pense
mais c'est très bien sont des joueurs
prometteurs ils sont en l' équipe de
France U17 c'est très très bien
maintenant parlait de pépit mais si
c'était vraiment des pépites ils serait
ben il y en aurait au moins un qui qui
évoluerait même à 17 ans en Ligue 1
après il y a Johan K qui joue à l'Est
Monaco pour l'instant il n'a pas joué
avec les enc Lig mais il est dans
l'équipe de a pas joué voilà il a pas
joué parce que moi pour moi Milan
l'italien de 15 ans là qui est rentré
qui est rentré au minor voilà parce que
une pépite si on peut parler d'une
pépite ppite même à 17 ans c'est très
jeune mais si c'est une pépite ben ce
serait déjà un joueur qui é vololuait en
Ligue 1 donc pour moi on peut pas on
peut pas appeler ça des pépites on peut
appeler des des joueurs prometteurs mais
il y a tellement tellement de joueurs
qui passent en équipe nationale des
jeunes et qui malheureusement ne font
pas carrière professionnelle à haut
niveau dans le football que c'est encore
un petit peu prématuré de dire que ça va
être des grands joueurs oui donc pour
vous c'est pas forcément gage de réussit
de réussir une compétition comme celle
c'est bien parti c'est bien parce que
parce que par exemplean a marqué quand
même lors de cette Coupe du monde oui TR
buts non mais c'est c'est bien c'est
bien c'est dans dans leur compétition
moins de U17 euh au niveau mondial ils
arrivent à performer maintenant le
chemin est encore long et encore une
fois même si 17 ans c'est jeune il y a
des joueurs qui jouent déjà à très haut
niveau euh à cet âge-là et là on peut
parler de pépite pour l'instant ce sont
ce sont pour moi des joueurs qui sont
prometteurs très prometteur on va dire
celui qui est peut-être assez prometteur
c'est Yam zag qui est un défenseur
latéral il joue au PSG en U19 il a déjà
inscrit 5 buts et délivré 11 passes
décisiv l'année dernière en 2022 2023
c'est un c'est un joueur peut-être qu'il
aura sa chance dans les prochaines
années au PSG parce qu'il a il a signé
déjà son contrat professionnel mais il
ne joue pas encore voilà il ne joue pas
encore avec le PSG au niveau
professionnelac
oui enfin je pense que pour bon intégrer
des jeunes dans l'équipe du PSG bon
l'année dernière ils l'ont fait mais
cette année c'est un peu plus un peu
plus difficile ils ont eu les les des
retours de avec bichatu et bon voilà il
a pas pas réussi il est parti ce qu'il y
a faut les garder voilà c'est ça c'est
le le plus difficile c'est ça parce que
s'il joue pas ils vont ils partiront ils
partiront dans d'autres clubs à
l'étranger bon c'est dommage bon on a
besoin je pense que si en arrière
latéral au
PSG ils en ont besoin ils ont ils sont
pas fournis avec les blessés en plus
qu'il y a ils sont pas ils sont pas
fournis c'est un gage de confiance pour
un club enfin pour zaguier d'avoir un
club comme le PSG qui lui offre un
contrat pro dès ses 17 ans après voilà
reste à être avoir des matchs accumuler
du temps de jeu en Ligue 1 et une ce
genre de compétition a pu peut-être lui
permettre il a je crois adresser un très
beau centre qui a qui a permis
l'ouverture du score le seul but en en
quart de finale face à à l'oubékistan ça
peut lui permettre de se mettre en
lumière alors le PSG va-t-il le mettre
va-t-il lui donner du temps de jeu ou
est-ce qu'il va servir de monnaie
d'échange peut-être dans dans le futur
transfert on le saura par la suite faut
qu'il arrive à performer en en Jes
League aussi ça c'est important je pense
aussi sur les trois Z qui sont présents
si vous deviez mettre une petite pièce
peut-être sur un de ou trois joueurs qui
seront en équipe de France peut-être
plus tard chez les chez les grands moi
je dis l'arrière latéralu vu le poste
plutôt en
défensefense a grgory je je mettrai
plutôt une pièce sur lui très mavais en
pronostic après si on regarde au vu au
vu des des performances il y a quand
même voilà
Gomis tiam gomiz qui a déjà des matchs
en en Ligue 2 donc il a déjà un peu plus
d'expérience que c'est autres compè mais
il est dans un secteur très très fermé
qui est qui est l'attaque qui est très
bouché voilà il y a beaucoup
malheureusement de profils qui arrivent
et des des profils très prometteurs et
déjà très performants en équipe de
France en tout cas on leur souhaite bon
courage pour la la suite de leur
carrière nous allons maintenant passer
au programme de l'émission aujourd'hui
nous allons parler de golf le prodige
français Victor dubisson prend
finalement sa retraite à 33 ans on
reviendra également sur les débuts de
Victor webanama en NBA le club de San
anonio est-il vraiment un bon club pour
Victor wemanama mais avant de parler de
ces thèmes on va parler football on va
continuer à parler
[Musique]
football on va donc continuer à parler
football et plus précisément du
championnat de National le FC Versailles
va mieux après un début de saison
poussif les joueurs viennent d'enchaîner
deux grosses victoires une contre nî sur
le score de 6 à 0 et une autre sur le
score de 4 à1 contre éepinal c'est la
première fois que Versailles enchaîne
deux victoires consécutives cette saison
grâce à ses bonnes performances le club
est désormais 8e du championnat avec un
match en moins une bonne période qui
coïncide avec le départ de l'entraîneur
Laurent pelade et de l'arrivée sur le
banc de Grégory vigal est-ce qu'on s'est
finalement trompé sur le FC Versailles
oui ou non c'est la question sur cette
thématique partagez partagez ah non pour
vous euh Pierre Chevalier allez-y non je
je DIRIS non parce que c'est assumez
vraiment vos idées heinassel un
gladiateur
on verra à la fin comme dit jeano c'est
à la fin à la fin du bal qu'on paye les
musiciens mais on verra la fin du
championnat non le le fait de d'aller au
bout de la pensée en disant on s'est on
s'est trompé sur sur quoi est-ce que
c'est sur le début de saison est-ce que
c'est sur le niveau
global mal on on a dit que sportivement
ils étaient moins forts que l'année
l'année précédente ça je crois que c'est
toujours c'est toujours valable même
s'il y a eu cet électrochoc du départ de
Perlade un changement d'entraîneur et
bah c'est une fois sur deux en fait dans
dans les équipes de sport collectif que
ce choc que ce choc psychologique est
positif euh et bon bah là ça tombe ça
tombe ouais moi je dirais une fois sur
deux mais donc là ça tombe ça tombe bien
ils ont ils enchaînent les victoire
premier petit bémol les deux les deux
grosses victoires que vous avez rappelé
sont contre deux équipes du bas de
classement du bas bas de classement donc
certes faut les mettre là les 6-0 le
premier set faut le mettre et les 41
aussi mais ce sont des équipes qui qui
vont qui vont lutter pour ne pas
descendre derrière il y a il y a un
match reporté contre Orléan qui aurait
été un bon test dans le dans le milieu
dans le milieu tableau ou il a été
reporté parce qu'il y avait des bouts de
verre sur sur la pelouse voilà donc
toujours ses problèmes de problèmes de
terrain ça s'est toujours posé donc pour
l'instant je on s'est pas trompé
là-dessus aussi c'est un manque le stade
à domicile le vrai stade domicile de de
Versailles et puis là une 8e position
avec certains matchs en retard le une
victoire pour pourrait leur faire
recoller à la premère au 5e je crois au
5è qui est ran voilà le classement qui
s'affiche donc pour l'instant ventreemou
on s'est pas trop trompé sur le fait de
dire que c'est le niveau sportif est
moins est moins fort que l'année
dernière le vestiaire semble aller mieux
ça c'est et le groupe semble aller mieux
il va y avoir un test le 18 décembre
contre le Red Star et ça là on sera donc
à versaill enfin à versaill à domicile à
versaill à Paris à Paris jeambois contre
le Red Star et là on sera vraiment si on
sa'est Al pas forcément trompé on est on
s'était dit que c'était moins fort mais
on s'était dit que qu'il serait quand
même au rendez-vous sans doute pas de la
monter cette saison ça pour ça ils ont
pas le choix dans la date c'est c'est
enchaîner les matchs et les victoires
qui qui donneront qui donneront le tout
donc je pense qu'on pour l'instant on
s'est pas trompé et on demande à voir il
y a des effets
positifs et des bons résultats gros test
qui arrive le 18
i Jean qu'est-ce vous en pensez est-ce
qu'il n'y a pas ce quand même ce ce choc
psychologique comme l'a rappelé Pierre
Chevalier alors oui j'étais je suis
entièrement d'accord a ce que Pierre
vient de dire effectivement une fois sur
deux on parle de choc psychologique
maintenant est-ce que c'est vraiment ça
parce qu'il a bien il a bien souligné l'
bien rappelé les deux victoires qui ne
sont pas quand même à Boué hein ce sont
deux victoires et deux belles victoires
mais ce sont face à des clubs qui sont
en bas du tableau donc je pense que on
peut on peut pas dire on peut pas dire
il y a eu de victoires parce qu'il y a
eu un ch un choc psychologique non on
peut pas on peut pas il va falloir voir
la prochaine confrontation avec un club
du même on va dire du même classement
rencontre c'est contre le Red Star les
premers du classement et là bon là là là
ils vont savoir vraiment s'il y a eu un
choc psychologique là on va vraiment on
va vraiment déterminer et se rendre
compte mais pour l'instant je je pense
pas qu'on puisse parler que que qu' ait
eu un choc psychologique par rapport au
résultats qui viennent d'aligner on peut
pas on peut pas dire ça pr oui c'est
trop prè et puis le sportif ne reflète
pas le résultat sportif ne reflète pas
systématiquement le le le l'état
d'esprit du du vestiaire là pour
l'instant avec deux victoires contre des
équipes encore une fois qui étaient en
bas du tableau donc on va voir quand il
va falloir faire preuve de solidarité
sur le terrain pour accrocher des
grosses équipes en haut du tableau ou
des équipes qui avec lesquelles ils vont
se battre pour accrocher la première
partie du tableau là on va voir s'il y a
vraiment l'état d'esprit est là si
effectivement il a eu ce choc
psychologique et si c'est bénéfique et
positif mais pour l'instant pour moi
c'est trop prématuré et vous y croyez
quand même à ce choc quand même avec un
coach qui
part l'adjoint qui reprend
l'équipe l'entraîneur c'est le fusible
on le sait dans tous les sports c'est
comme ça c'est plus facile pu c'est la
mod de plus en plus mais c'est plus
facile de de de se séparer d'un
entraîneur que de se séparer de de
quelques joueurs donc c'est c'est le
fusible c'est la facilité maintenant il
croire moi comme disait pierre c'est une
fois sur deux moi je dirais plutôt que
c'est une fois sur sur C parce que à
part si vraiment l'entraîneur c'est
euh ouais si c'est bon mais sinon on va
rester pouri parce que sinon après je
prends un carton et non mais sinon voilà
si ça marche c'est parce que le problème
n'est n'est pas spécialement celui de
l'entraîneur c'est rarement celui de
l'entraîneur donc c'est pour ça que moi
j'ai personnellement je n'y crois pas
toujours Gregory canalé mais c'est trop
précoce ça je suis d'accord pour voilà
je suis partagé parce que de dire est-ce
qu'on s'est trompé ou pas là il y a eu
deux matchs deux très belles victoires
aussi il faut le souligner il y a une
victoire si buusin alors dans un match
un peu particulier 6-0 pardon dans un
c'est 4atre buts à 6-0 et 4 buts à 1
dans un match où il y a eu je crois
trois ou quatre expulsions deux
expulsions assez précoce du côté de de
nî voilà de N dans les 30 premières
minutes ils étaient réduit à
ctire 4 ensuite face à à éepinal donc on
serait tenté de dire oui peut-être qu'on
s'est trompé moi je disais la dernière
fois qu'on avait laissé trop peu de
temps à Laurent Perlade moi je vais
quand même attendre voir la suite de la
saison d'avoir effectivement des
adversaires un peu plus relevés en face
du du FC Versailles après ça confirme
aussi quelque chose c'est que on le
disait aussi la dernière fois dans le
championnat de National une victoire ou
deux victoires bah très vite ça peut
vous replacer dans la course alors
peut-être pas pour la montée mais en
tout cas ils sont pas si loin que ça il
suffit qu'il gagne ce match en retard
face à à Orléan il serait à 4 points de
la 2uxème place synonyme de monter de
l'autre côté bon on sait qu'à partir de
la 13e place toutes les équipes
descendent descendent il y a six
descentes dans ce ce championnat
national vers le championnat national 2
donc tout va très vite alors est-ce que
le FC Versailles a fait le bon choix en
se séparant de Laurent Perlade et en
mettant Grégory vinal qui rappelons-le a
quand même une expérience avec les
groupes jeunes il a été responsable de
la préformation à l'OM il a entraîné les
jeunes des Glasgow Rangers lui qui a eu
une carrière du côté il a joué à
Liverpool au Glasgow Rangers ça il a
joué il a joué en première legue
notamment donc peut-être que cette
expérience il va la mettre à à profit
maintenant attendons de voir je pense
qu'il est trop tôt encore pour dire si
on si on s'est trompé ou pas sur le
choix vigal et le remplacement de
Laurent perlad philiip
volac moi pareil ils sont pas loin de la
deuxème place ils sont pas loin non plus
de derrière ou ce qui me fait plus peur
c'est plutôt euh ils vont jouent pas le
weekend prochain ils jouent après contre
rest star et après c'est la trêve et et
ça va faire quand même ils vont
reprendre que je crois le vers le 15 15
janvier je me dis comment se prononcer
je sais pas le 15 janvier coupance ser
oui mais eu il ils y seront pas en Coupe
de France ils y sont pas en Coupe de
France donc ils vont peut-être faire ils
vont peut-être faire le match parce que
Orléan aussi est éliminé je crois bien
et ben ils vont peut-être faire le match
en retard le le premier dimanche de le
premier weekend de de janvier mais je
trouve que on parle il faut attendre
c'est vrai que comme tout le monde l'a
dit le resta on va voir ce que ça va
donner le resta c'est bon on peut dire
que c'est à domicile ou pas à domicile
le restar c'est c'est pareil mais il
vaut mieux prendre le
restar enfin chez eux que enfin à
versaill que à jeamboin que comment que
là-bas parce que ils ont quand même 8
points d'avance sur le deuxème ils ont
c'est quand même la GR é a de
championnat le lgement devant et ensuite
c'est assez rerré derrière mais il faut
faire attention verseill avait beaucoup
aussi il y a quelques temps et il y a
quelques saisons ou la pas saison
dernière ils avaient beaucoup d'avance
aussi et il comme le Paris FC aussi à un
moment comme voilà mais non moi je pense
que faut encore attendre faut encore
attendre pour voir allez je me dis fin
fin janvier effectivement deux
championnats je suis d'accord avec vous
Michel sur le Red Star je pense qui fera
la course en tête et qui remportera sans
sans grande surprise sauf grande
surprise ce championn national par
contre tout est ouvert derrière et moi
je dis versaill pourquoi pas on ne sait
jamais en enchaînant r C'est possible
pour vous mais c'est toujours possible
mathématiquement tant que c'est c'est
c'est pas impossible on pourra pas dire
que versaill ne peut pas prétendre à
cette montée en fait tout va très vite
une victoire ça vous replace très bien
comme une défaite ça peut vous mettre
très vite dans la zone rouge est-ce
qu'on a pas été trop dur aussi avec
versaill en sachant qu' y a beaucoup de
nouveaux joueurs aussi gens qui sont qui
sont arrivés cette année nouvel
entraîneur nouveaux joueurs le temps que
ça se mette en place tout simplement ah
oui tout à fait tout à fait le on l'a
dit plusieurs fois sur le plateau il
faut le temps au temps laisser le temps
a temp surtout aux entraîneurs là en
l'occurrence ils l'ont pas gardé
l'entraîneur ils l'ont il l'ont limogé
assez rapidement euh c'est c'est
compliqué compliqué parce que
quelquefois il faut il faut même
quelquefois une saison pour que pour que
pour que un entraîneur puisse mettre en
place son jeu donc donc là on on peut
pas dire qu'on a laissé le temps que le
club a laissé le temps à l'entraîneur de
de de mettre en place quoi que ce soit
donc là on repart avec un nouvel
entraîneur en en pleine saison et avec
la première partie de la saison en plus
donc là effectivement il va falloir
mettre laisser le temps et mettre
laisser cet entraîneur mettre en place
son jeu maintenant on peut pas on peut
pas on peut pas dire aujourd'hui que ce
sera bien que ce sera bon ouou mauvais
on ne sait pas là on est un petit peu
dans l'inconnu donc là c'est pour ça
qu'on attend avec impatience les
prochaines les prochaines les prochains
matchs voir un petit peu où ils en sont
moi je pense qu'on a été dur c'est plus
par rapport au au terrain leur terrain
on a surtout été là par rapport à ça il
jou pas chez eux ils jouent à jamboin il
y a pas de spectateur il y a pas de
voilà je pense qu'on a été plutôt dur
par rapport à ça bon on a été dur aussi
quand il y a eu tous ces problèmes avec
les entraîneurs avec la avec le le staff
et tout mais bon je pense qu'on a mais
ouais non je trouve qu'on a pas été sur
sur résultat très très dur moi je trouve
pas on a été réaliste et pu exigent en
fait exig il nous ont habitué enfin
habitué ils nous ont fait rêver avec le
leur épopé en Coupe de France c'était
maintenant déjà de saison
et exactement et exigeant exigeant sur
le niveau et et sur sur la mise en place
qui semblait quand même malgré tout qui
semblait
cohérente mais jeen l'a rappelé pas de
pas de temps autant on laisse pas on
laisse pas sa chance au produit à
l'entraîneur et j'ai l'impression que
plus on monte de niveau en sport
collectif on parlait de Vals des
entraîneurs plus plus la pression est
forte sur l'entraîneur il y a une
personne le fusible le fusible qui saute
qui saute assez rapidement dès que les
résultats sont sont pas ceux qui était
escontés donc reste à savoir si les
objectifs étaient clairement fixés en
début de saison s'il avait sa feuille de
route et bon a priori il était il est
aux yeux des propriétaires pas pas au
rendez-vousion d'entraîneurs qui ont été
licenciés depuis depuis le le début de
saison là c'est c'est inimaginable la ST
est Ding en Ligue 1 il y a que deux
entraîneurs qui sont là depuis plus d'un
an sur les clubs de Lig ah ouais ça veut
tout direusible
ah oui alors bilan de versaill en tout
cas pour pour cette saison 5 victoires 5
nuls et qu défaites pour l'instant le
prochain match sera donc contre le Red
Star le 18 décembre prochain on va
maintenant passer à votre envolé Grégory
le moment le plus fort de cette émission
le moment incournable de cette émission
alors de quoi allez-vous parler
aujourd'hui alors de cette grosse
surprise survenue hier dans la journée
de mardi alors que nous étions en train
de préparer cette émission à seulement
33 ans Victor du Buisson met terme à sa
carrière de golfeur il a annoncé à nos
confrères du journal L'Équipe le sportif
range les clubs après 13 années passées
sur le circuit professionnel nous
l'avions croisé à plusieurs reprises au
Golf National de 50 ans evvin comme lors
de l'édition 2017 de l'Open de France
voulu demandier Michel s'il était
content de revenir sur le parcours
cinquantinoise qui avait donné à
l'époque une séquence assez
croustillante regardez ravi ouais c'est
très bel événement et je en plus je suis
avec mes amis qui m' ou bagag à
l'aéroport de Nice et ouais qui qui qui
sortent
d'un d'une belle soirée d'hier j'ai
encore la
tenue au PMU à gauche deio balbonne
surtout n'hésitez pas appelez on interv
pas mal de personnes il vous considè
comme peut-être l'un des favoris du coup
dans dans le top 5 en tout cas la fin
vous sentez vous êtes bon non on peut
pas c'est difficile à dire après le
premier jour surtout enfin c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment difficile à dire
c'est un cont tellement difficile
heureusement que le plateau le NRE est
là les balles de golf en chocolat
n'hésitez surtout pas ah c'est le le top
du top gratiner à l'intérieur avec
couliis
caramel ça vous ça vous fait un 19e trou
d'anologie bon la nuit semble-t-il avait
été courte pour lui mais cette séquence
témoigne bien de il é en plein tournoi
ouais c'était le deuxième jour de de
l'Open de France mais cette séquence
témoigne bien de ce qu' le publicique
chez lui sa sympathie une bonne humeur
qui lui avait d'ailleurs valu le surnom
de cactus boy par les Américains nous
sommes en 2014 au championnat du monde
de match play à Marana en Arizona
victoire du Buisson fait face à
l'Australien Jason day en finale alors
que les deux hommes sont à égalité la
balle du français se retrouve coincée au
beau milieu des cactus tout le monde
pense que le coup est injouable sauf lui
le golfeur s'en sort magistralement il
perd il perdra ce match certes au 23e
trou mais sa légende est écrite ROR
mackilroy elle dira même à l'époque peu
importe qui a gagné Victor dubisson et
mon nouveau héros
un héros qu'on auraité aimé qu'on aurait
aimé voir plus haut car il avait tout du
prodige numéro 1 mondial amateur fin
2009 pendant 8 semaines le golfeur a
fait son entrée sur le circuit
professionnel en 2010 le sportif sissé
jusqu'au 15e rang mondial en 2014 soit
le meilleur classement pour un Français
dans l'histoire mais depuis plus de gros
coups d'éclat alors du Buisson
rimerat-il avec déception pas pour lui
en tout cas voici ses propos au au
journal L'Équipe beaucoup de personnes
diront que j'aurais pu faire plus que
j'aurais pu être numéro 1 mondial mais
ma force c'est de me satisfaire de ce
que j'ai eu je m'en contente amplement
je ne vis pas dans le regret à ressasser
tout le temps des beaux moments qu'il en
a eu en effet victire du Buisson compte
deux titres sur le Tour européen de
victoire lors du Turkish open à Antalia
en 2013 devant Tiger Woods excuser du
peu puis en 2015 également l'année 2014
est sans doute le mais de sa carrière le
français fait partie de la team Europe
victorieuse de la Raider Cup qui se qui
se dispute en Écosse il contribue
largement au succès européens en
marquant 2,5 points en 3 matchs 2014
c'est aussi l'année de ces deux
meilleurs résultats en grandchlem une 9e
place au British Open et une 7e place
lors de l'USPGA et des moments
formidables lui-même le dit à l'équipe
mais il va pouvoir désormais profiter de
sa vie car sa carrière n'a pas toujours
été facile 15 années seules
recroqueevill sur lui-même et j'avais de
plus en plus de mal à supporter la vie
sur le Tour c'est formidable mais la
solitude était devenue extrêmement
pesante en tout cas pour moi j'ai
l'impression d'avoir atteint mes limites
et je sais que je peux trouver du
plaisir ailleurs j'en suis convaincu je
tourne la page mais la vie continue ça
montre là toute la difficulté du sport
individuel au quotidien malgré le strass
les paillettes les Priz money c'est une
vie loin des siens et seule souvent dans
les hôtels une pratique du sport de haut
niveau assez frustrant assez frustrante
où l'on prend du plaisir uniquement dans
le résultat alors pour que le golf reste
une passion pour dubisson pour dubisson
voilà j'en perd mon latin c'était pour
moi la meilleure des décisions bonvent à
toi Victor profite de la vie une vie de
coaching désormais et comme le dit très
bien la Fédération Française de Golf sur
son site internet s'il réussit à
transmettre à ses futurs élèves ne
serait-ce qu'une infime fraction de son
talent club en main le golf français
encore de beau jour devant lui bravo
Grégory mag j'ai j'ai beaucoup j'ai
beaucoup bugé aujourd'hui déjà petite
réaction par rapport à la vidéo qu'on a
vu de Victor du buisson à la sortie de
son je crois deuxè tour à l'OP de France
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez à Philippe
Philippe pierre c'est Victor c'est
Victor du Buisson il y a deux choses qui
m'ont marqué qui m'ont marqué chez lui
c'est que premièrement c'est un diamant
brut en terme de en terme de talent
talent golfique Dieu sait que le le golf
est un sport difficile technique mais
lui il avait cette aisance enfin il
avait je parle je parle je parle déjà au
passé il a cette aisance technique qui
qui qui en fait un un petit
extraterrestre et et effectivement les
les pros dont vous avez rappelé les
propos ne son ne s'y sont pas trompés
là-dessus euh étincelant rider Cup aussi
avec avec les meilleurs parmi les
meilleurs contre les meilleurs
absolument exceptionnel et la deuxième
chose et c'est ce qui nous plaisait je
pense au niveau au niveau amateur c'est
que c'est que c'est un c'est un homme
comme tout le monde c'est un golfeur
sportif certes de haut niveau mais qui
qui s'accordait qui s'accordait toutes
les tout t tous les plaisirs et les
bonheurs qui accompagnent une partie de
golf ou qui accompagne un tournoi et
effectivement là ça ça a dû ça a dû
faire suite à une petite une petite
touchette avec les amis voilà une légère
touchette partie dans le décor mais mais
il était là le lendemain et il fallait
pas lui demander comment comment et
pourquoi mais et il était capable il
était capable de shooter un de shooter
un 70 un Mo- 2 ou au national ou
ailleurs alors que alors qu'il avait été
un petit peu sur des soirées olé olé
mais mais ça ça c'est je pense que ce
que j'ai trouvé ça fait partie de
victoire du Buisson et on va le
regretter parce que
c'est déjà déjà c'est un sacré joueur de
golf et et c'est c'est un un golfeur qui
rassure tout le monde en gros euh nous
dans dans notre quotidien d'amateur euh
avec les excès les excès de la veille ou
du lendemain mais on est on est capable
aussi de temps en temps de sortir un
coup lui il en sortait il en sortait 70
jolis coups sur un sur un parcours euh
le seul petit bémol c'est que c'est
c'était une individualité dure à gérer
en collectif il il finit d'ailleurs son
son interview dans l'équipe avec une une
dédicace à Pascal Grizot donc qui est le
président président de la Fédération
Française de GO désormais mais qui était
le capitaine de l'équipe de France
amateur avec Victor dans ses rangs ils
se sont pognés tout ce qui tout ce qui
pouvait parce que parce que je pense que
dans l'esprit de Pascal c'est c'est le
haut niveau et et le et les tournois ça
se prépare ça se vit et puis ça il faut
être organisé et programmé pour ça
Victor il avait il avait ses côtés cette
liberté aussi dans dans le jeu de gale
mais il il a il a reconnu que que les
difficultés étaient de son fait à lui
Victor et que la féd et Pascal Grisot
notamment l'a toujours soutenu et poussé
donc c'est un ouais ouais c'est un c'est
un champion original et un grand
champion qui qui tire sa révérence je
pense qu'on le reverra quand même sur
les sur les parcours et ailleurs mais
une sacrée personnalité attachante on
sent que vous avez très envie de faire
une partie de golf avec Vict dubisson ça
ça je serais extrêmement preneur
j'apprendrai beaucoup pour pour la près
ou pendant la partie de de golf les deux
général c'est un
ensemble pour l'arquer après Jean
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez retraite
sportive à 33 ans dans le golf c'est pas
forcément courant ah non c'est pas
forcément courant parce que il l'a dit
lui-même on peut considérer que c'est
jeune que c'est très jeune lui ben il a
pris le choix dans la date de son départ
à la retraite bon ben on peut pas lui en
vouloir et contrairement avec des grands
sportifs du même sport que que Tiger
Woods qui lui a 48 ans ben après un
grave accident après un grave accident
de voiture remet ça ben voilà on a un
victoire du buisson qui éta un grand
champion aussi et et qui lui s'arrête à
33 ans et voilà ce que disait pierre et
ce que j'aimais bien c'est qu'il était
un petit peu différent du du du du
stéréotype du golfeur c'était un gars
qui quand on sait que le golf demande
maîtrise demande concentration et il
l'avait mais c'était c'est là qu' voyait
que c'était un joueur doué parce que
justement lui se permettait de sortir
des sentiers battus bon d'aller faire un
petit peu un petit peu un petit écart en
plein tournoi mais ça ça voilà ça ça
fait partie ça fait partie du personnage
et c'est pas ce qu'on va se regretter le
plus parce que on a on a on est quand
même toujours dans un milieu qui est
très très très très posé
très très codifié et là lui il sortait
un petit peu
de donc c'est voilà on va le regretter
pour c'est jeunes mais c'est un choix et
c'est un choix réfléchi et je pense que
ça ça touché à sa vie privée et là il a
expliqué je pense que c'est c'est c'est
naturel parce qu'il s' prend plus
plaisir parce que c'est un garçon qui en
jouant prenit énormément de plaisir donc
s' prend plus de plaisir
forcément ça va vite le gaver et je
pense qu'en plus vu le caractère qu'il a
c'est pas bon il arrête au bon moment
qu'
sent après derrière on a eu quelques
échos sur un peu l'état d'esprit de
Victor du Buisson par rapport au golf il
aimait pas forcément le golf c'est ça
qui est assez étonnant il nimait pas
forcément le golf à la base parce qu'il
était doué dou qu'il était doué et que
finalement il a continué dans cette voie
mais il n'aimait pas le golf en fait à
la base et d'ailleurs il associe le golf
à une certaine forme de pression parce
que quand il est passé professionnel il
raconte que dans le sud de la France il
vivait avec sa mère et sa sœur dans une
chambre de bonne et il avait aussi toute
cette pression sur lui et c'est quelque
chose qui a pas forcément été positif
alors après ça a été positif sur la
suite de sa carrière mais ça pu être
aussi une forme de de frustration il a
pris du plaisir à la rider Cup il a dit
mais au début de sa carrière c'était
plus du stress Philippe qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez vous de de cette retraite
assez jeunes quand Jean dit qu'il a pas
le choix dans la date moi je dis qu'il a
choisi sa date de toute façon donc il a
plus sa car carte commandant pro il
avait été retiré parce qu'il était 287e
mondial je crois bien à la Dubaï tour je
crois que c'est ça ouais après c'est
Bell finalement était il y a quasiment
10 ans finalement quand on regarde mais
je pense que non il arrête parce que
voilà mais je pense qu'il veut devenir
il veut pas rester au comment entraîneur
au niveau et il veut il veut être
commment entraîneur au niveau amateur
mais je pense que il va trouver au
niveau amateur on va le retrouver sur
les les golfs du du 78 et et peut-être
que Pierre tu vas peut-être on sait pas
tu vas peut-être prendre quelques il y a
que deux personnes dans sa a priori on
compté dans sa dans sa carrière en en
tant qu'entraîneur Roger Damiano qui l'a
mis au golf qui l'a mis au golf à Cannes
et puis après il est passé dans les
mains du druide benoî du Colombier et
qui qui est le seul qui a essayé et
réussi pour parti à cadrer un peu la
bête et puis à à essayer de de essayer
d'orienter l'artiste qui est qu'il est
et et de justement de le faire performer
en enchaînant les tournois mais je crois
qu'au final et ça c'est c'est vrai pour
avoir discuté avec pas mal de de
professionnels qui sont sur les
différents niveaux des des circuits des
circuits européens et mondiaux la
solitude la solitude du champion de golf
et de la championne de golf c'est pareil
chez les filles qui sont qui sont loin
loin de leur famille quasiment toute
l'année parce que finalement aussi selon
les hémisphères on joue quasiment toute
l'année sur des sur des grands tournois
de golf et ça ça finit par le ronger
parce que c'est c'est c'est c'est un
c'est un bonhomme profondément humain
profondément Antier là-dessus et il a il
a besoin d'affection il a besoin de
d'être entouré de deux c'est très proche
il y en a pas beaucoup et et pour le
coup son son choix est son choix est
légitime après 33 ans c'est beaucoup
trop jeune parce que le problème aussi
c'est qu' il a pas été remplacé
c'estàdire que nos champions français on
on on les cherche dans la durée et là
Victor c'était c'était quand même depuis
depuis les années 2010 c'était quand
même une sacré trs belle promesse il a
été quand même j qu'au plus haut niveau
et pour l'instant ça tarde un peu on a
Perez péez qui est là et qui commence à
durer il y avait Antoine Rosner il y a
il y a toujours il y a toujours Antoine
et et Victor Perez voilà on a c'est avec
lui c'est une de nos étoiles qui qui
s'éteint un petit peu dans le monde du
golf français international ça sera le
mot de la fin sur cette thématique en
tout cas Pierre Chevalier on a compris
vous êtes partant pour une partie de
golf avec Victor duisson alors après
Victor dubisson nous allons passer à un
autre Victor Victor wembanama le prodige
du basket auiginaire du chînet rquancour
affiche de très bonne une très bonne
feuille de statistique depuis le début
de la saison en 18 matchs il tourne à
19,3 points 9,7 rebonds 2,9 contre mais
les Spurs ne brillent pas du tout depuis
le début de la saison ils affichent un
bilan de trois victoires et 16 défaites
depuis le début octobre ils sont sur une
série même de 14 matchs sans victoire
ils font partie des plus mauvaises
équipes de la saison pour l'instant
alors la question sur cette thématique
son anono est-il vraiment le bon club
pour Victor wembanama
oui ou non voilà c'est que des oui pour
vous Jean oui pour vous Grégory canalé
oui pour vous philiip volac et oui pour
vous Pierre Chevalier philiip volac
pourquoi toute façon il a été drafté il
déjà l'année dernière son Antonio
c'était pas c'était pas terrible déjà on
précise que ce n'est pas un choix de
Victor W non non
non auats-unis le premier choix prend le
choix qu' veut dans tous les basketteurs
qui peuvent intégrer la Ligue l'année
l'année suivante ouais non il avait bien
il avait bien commencé mais il a des
stats qui sont peut-être derniers enfin
il reste sur 14 défaites consécutives je
crois ou 16 14 ouais 14 mais il est pas
bon il a raté quelques matchs mais il a
pas a raté un match un match mais je
veux dire je trouve que il a des il a
des bonnes States je veux dire bon il
est pas rooki des deux derniers mois
octobre non c'est octobre et novembre
ouais oui parce que justement ça ça a
des conséquences he d'ailleurs sur
victorama il n'est pas du coup rooki des
mois d'octobre et novembre il a été
devancé par chet holmgen drafté en 2è
position par oklahama City dans la
conférence wouest une équipe qui a pour
le coup 13 victoires et 6 défaitesfté
l'année dernière l'année dernière ou oua
ouis donc je pense que non non il y a
pas photo par rapport à rooky ou sur les
de derniers mois il est s'il est 2e
c'est c'est déjà c'est déjà pas mal mais
je crois qu'il joue encore une grosse
équipe cette nuit je crois à venir euh
je crois et contre Minesota ouais ouais
ouais donc euh il y a quelques il y a
quelques défaites qui sont pas passées
loin tu vois ils ont craqué ils ont
craqué en en dans le 4e quartant et et
bon il il fait il fait ses comment il
fait ses classes hein il fait ses ses
classes bon faut pas qu'il se faut pas
qu'il B c'est ça la question est-ce que
c'est le bon club finalement réponds à
la question oua parce que c'est le bon
club euh je dis euh non on va dire non
on va dire non mais bon ou mais il pas
le choix ouais mais il a pas le choix
oualier moi je dirais oui c'est oui
c'est le bon choix pour deux raisons la
première c'est que c'est le principe de
la draft c'est c'est c'est comme c'est
comme ça que c'est fait aux États-Unis
c'estàdire que le le le meilleur le
meilleur rooky possible le meilleur le
meilleur jeune possible est attribué à
une à une équipe qui est moins bien
classée la saison précédente et la
deuxième raison c'est pour ZPR Popovic
c'est au moins pour le au moins pour le
coach pour le pops ça Tony Parker avait
suffisamment rappelé quand quand wby
était appelé à à rejoindre les Spurs il
va il va le il va le il va le couver il
va le formater là il il y a pas
forcément urgence ni ni ni justement
faut pas non plus perdre perdre de temps
je trouve que Victor est W est est au
rendez-vous en terme de stade perso il
peut pas tout faire ça c'est sûr que
c'est le reste de l'effectif qui qui est
peut-être un petit peu plus light par
rapport au aux autres franchises de la
NB est c'est une équipe très jeune voilà
hyper jeune mais par contre bon lui il
est au rendez-vous il a il a il a
notamment très bien démarré avec avec
plusieurs doubles double et puis des des
des stats des stats qui sont très
complètes c'est ça moi c'est ça qui me
qui me fascine aussi avec lui c'est que
qu'on l'a on l'a suffisamment rappelé
c'est un joueur complet très grand donc
très à l'aise dans la raquette mais qui
est capable de choter à longue distance
de dribler et puis et puis de courir
assez vite malgré ses grands compat et
donc je pense qu'il est au rendez-vous
il a fait le bon choix il va pas
forcément rester peut-être être des
plein de saisons mais en tout cas celle
qu'il passe en ce moment peut-être la
suivante avec Popovic ça sera de ça sera
du bon pour la suite Grégory can ça a
été rappelé par Pierre chose importante
il n'a pas vraiment eu le choix puisque
c'est plutôt le club qui drafte le
joueur qui choisit le joueur
effectivement les Spurs pourquoi ils ont
eu ce ce choix numéro 1 c'est parce que
l'année dernière il faisaient partie des
deux moins moins bonnes équipes les les
deux plus mauvaise équipe de la saison
la saison passée après oui on regarde
l'histoire des Spurs l'histoire avec un
français notamment Tony Parker donc il
arrive quand même dans un terrain assez
favorable pour les les jeunes Français
et il y a Greg Popovic on sait Greg
Popovic a une fibre pour travailler avec
les jeunes joueurs alors oui on peut
être frustré du début de saison des
Spurs maintenant Victor wembanyama lui
individuellement il a ses stats ça va
peut-être je l'espère pas mais le privé
du titre de Rookie de l'année si les
Spurs continuent sur cette série
négative voilà 16 défaites 14 14
d'affilé et ses States individuelles
sont intéressantes peut-être qu'il doit
encore progresser sur certains points ça
son efficacité au tir notamment
peut-être perdre un peu moins de balles
par match aussi il doit progresser là
pour préciser il prend souvent les tirs
les plus importants de son équipe ou
donc il a déjà il a déjà un rôle
prépondérant c'est déjà le le patron de
cette équipe donc mauvais choix mais en
tout cas il il a pas choisi d'aller au
Spurs c'est plutôt les Spurs qui qui
l'ont choisi moi je pense qu'il a les
carte en main il est dans un bon
environnement à mon avis et on va voir
ça va être décisif cet environnement
peut-être un peu négatif collectivement
par qu'il y a une série de défaites
est-ce que ça va pas aussi l'aider à
grandir plus vite dans cette NBA c'est
c'est tout le mal que je souhaite en
tout cas Jean qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez tout a été dit là autour du
plateau si ce n'est que pour moi c'est
un bon trempelin on l'a déjà dit il a
pas eu le choix du
club il faut pas confondre ses
statistiques personnelles pardon et la
performance du groupe Pierre l' l'a dit
tout à l'heure lui il a quand même des
statistiques àolantes pour une première
saison en NBA mais il peut pas tout
faire sur le terrain donc le collectif
perd mais lui il grandit de de de match
en match et je pense que c'est pour moi
c'est un bon tremplin je pense aussi que
s'il veut performer et atteindre un très
haut niveau faudra pas qu'il reste dans
un club comme celui-là forcément après
après il n'a pas forcément son mot à
dire sur le choix du club après c'est
c'est le club qui décide à un moment de
l'échanger contre d'autres joueurs de
d'autres équipes oui oui non mais on est
bien d'accord mais à moment donné tout
tout tout toutes t négociations hein
donc à un moment donné je pense que
c'est quand même un garçon qui jusqu'à
présent a montré énormément
d'intelligence dans la gestion de sa
carrière sportive et donc à ce titre-là
on lui fait confiance pour pouvoir
grandir très rapidement au sein de la
NBA mais on peut pas lui lui reprocher
quoi que ce soit parce que il est il a
quand même des des des belles
statistiques personnelles et et
aujourd'hui bah il est dans une équipe
qui malheureusement ne performe pas donc
là c'est compliqué c'est très compliqué
mais pour moi le le être dans cette
équipe là pour moi c'est c'est un bon
c'est une bonne chose pour y a a qui son
de l'autre côté il y en a qui sont pas
trompés c'est les Spurs en particulier
avec une véritable wa Mania et et des
des des maillots qui se vendent à
laappel et on se rappelle on se rappelle
de l'accueil qui été fait à santio que
ça il y a que ça a que il y a que le
basket y a pas d'autres sport
contrairement à beaucoup d'autres villes
aux États-Unis avec les les sports qui
font recett il y a que le basket il y a
que les Spurs et donc c'est c'était
c'était le Messi le Messi annoncé et et
là à titre personnel on l'a rappelé il
est au rendez-vous mais pas son équipe
ne pas mais son équipe et voilà c'est
peut-être un peu plus jeune un peu plus
un petit peu plus faible autour moi DISM
qu'il est au rendez-vous des GIR moi
c'est le principal justement vous me
faites une belle transition à PhIP
on s'est pas communiqué avant le début
de l'émission on va maintenant parler
des Jeux Olympiques
[Musique]
2024 Jeux Olympiques 2024 donc une
information fait beaucoup parler depuis
quelques jours on connaît désormais les
tarifs des transports en commun pendant
la compétition pour financer une offre
de transport supplémentaire le forfait
spécial Joo coûtera cet été 16 € pour un
jour ou 70 € la semaine le tarif sera
dégressif en fonction du nombre de
journées le simple ticket de transport
coûtera 4 € contre 2,10 € actuellement
il y a donc de nombreuses critiques et
une remise en question de ces jeux
annoncés comme populaires cela se
rajoute au prix des billets pour les
Jeux Olympiques qui ont fait beaucoup
parler aussi ces derniers mois la
question sur cette thématique cet
événement est-il vraiment populaire
quand on voit tout ça non pour vous Jean
oui pour vous Grégory non pour vous
Philippe volac et non pour vous Pierre
Chevalier alors on va faire un petit
duel entre Grégory qui est seul contre
tous voilà je vais face à Philippe volac
face à Philippe volac allez-y prier
argument c'est de dire avant tout des
Jeux olympiques sont forcément
populaires c'est en tout cas une grande
fête qui arrive seulement tous les 4 ans
la dernière fois en France qu'il a eu
des des Jeux d'été même s'il y aura des
jeux d'hivers dans dans les Alpes ça a
été confirmé bah c'était il y a 100 ans
en 1924 et c'est un événement que tout
le monde attend avec impatience
maintenant euh il aura il aura les
arguments en compte moi ce que je
voulais dire sur le côté populaire il y
a quand même des choses qui sont euh qui
sont mises en place par le Comité
d'organisation au-delà des places aussi
le prix des places ça ça a fait
polémique mais il y aura des
possibilités de voir d'assister à ces JO
de manière gratuite il y a la cérémonie
d'ouverture la jauge a été certes revue
à la baisse mais on parle quand même de
300000 personnes qui sont sur les qu qui
pourront assister à cet événement quand
même qui est une première une cérémonie
des Jos en dehors d'un stade avec un
public qui pourra venir autour de cette
scène avec un un spectacle qu'on nous
permet qu'on nous qu'on nous promet
grandiose on imagine aussi des gens aux
fenêtres aussi qui pouront regarder la
la compé la sécurité ça ça reste à à à
éclaircir tous les points au niveau
sécuritaire moi je pense que aussi la la
partie populaire va se jouer sur
l'héritage on reproche souvent aux Joos
qui se sont déroulés par le passé à Rio
à Pékin de laisser des structures
complètement vides après les Jeux
Olympiques des structures qui ont été
construites uniquement pour pour ces
Jeux Olympiques et qui sont aujourd'hui
à l'abandon il y a un vrai travail qui
est fait sur l'héritage on peut citer du
côté de 50 ans vine la la colline
d'lancour qui n'était pas ouverte au
public avant les Jos et qui le sera
après il y aura des pistes de VTT un peu
comme au ski qui auront des couleurs
selon le niveau de difficulté de de de
ces pistes de VTT donc je pense qu'il y
a quand même un travail qui a été fait
par le comité d'organisation pour
essayer de les rendre populaires après
qu'il a des ratés ça j'en conviens et je
pense que Philippe va en parler mais en
tout cas je pense que le Paris populaire
et allez l'ID populaire est là selon
l'idée populaire est là selon moi Philip
volac qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
grégoryi moi je pense que c'est le
Comité olympique qui qui le veut
populaire ce qui est tout à fait logique
hein c'est eu qui c'est eux qui
organiseent donc c'est c'est tout à fait
logique euh ouvert à tous c'est leure
aussi un slogan je suis pas très
d'accord parce que déjà par rapport au
prix quand on sait que pour la cérémonie
d'ouverture c'est 2700 € et que pour la
natation c'est un des exemples c'est
1000 € c'est quand même pas beaucoup de
monde monde qui pourront qui pourront le
voir après je me dis le souci aussi
c'est que dans Paris quand on va aller
vouloir quand on va vouloir aller voir
des des comment des des enfin des
épreuves il y aura un périmètre de
sécurité périmètre de sécurité qui sera
qui sera énorme on pourra pas y aller
accéder comme comme on voudra je pense
que dans le 78 on pourra accéder
beaucoup beaucoup plus facilement je
pense mais je pense que c'est il y a une
contradiction je trouve entre le cojop
et ce que pense la population le déjà le
prix ouais ouais je pense qu'il y a une
contradiction et je trve plus on va plus
je sais pas ça redescend alors que
normalement ça devrait monter en
puissance et là je trouve qu'il y a pas
de
c'estramme plat mais c'est mais c'est
vrai alors que ça devrait monter bon va
peut-être attendre tout début 2024 parce
que c'est quand même dans ta tête c'est
Jo 2024 on est encore qu'en 2023 mais je
pense que il y a une contradiction et on
va voir et puis il y a il y a ça mais il
y a aussi tout ce qu'on parle de comment
de de attentat les risques les risques
de cyber sécurité cyber voilà ça je
pense que les cyber attaque les gens les
gens ils sont ils sont ils sont très
très méfiants et je pense que ce va ce
va en il y a quelques-uns qui vont pas
vouloir y aller Jean qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez alors al pour vous ce n'est
pas du tout populaire alors populaire on
va dire populaire oui sportivement après
voilà moi sachant que Paris va être
inaccessible en
véhicule puisque tout tout va être
verrouillé pour pour la sécurité pour le
déplacement il y aura beaucoup de zones
où on pourra pas accder non il y aura
énormément de zones pas pas beaucoup de
zones Paris intramuros faut pas y
compter à partir de de de de mai juin
vous pourrez vous pourrez plus circuler
dans Paris donc ça je vous le dis moi
euh donc déjà donc quand on dit
accessible à tous quand on sait qu'on
peut pas qu'on avoir énormément de
problèmes pour circuler et qu'on met le
prix des transports en commun où on
passe le ticket le ticket de métro à 4 €
et puis les les tarifs qu'on vient
d'annoncer à 70 € la semaine ou des
choses comme ça je peux pas appeler ça
populaire et à la portée de tout le
monde non c'est pas possible et pu tout
le monde se renvoie la bas c'est c'est
c'est c'est les transports qui sont
responsables qui mettent en place les
tarifs c'est pas le Comité olympique en
tout le monde personne ne prend parce
que des transports il y aura plus de
trains du coup ça augmente les prix en
gros c'est ça la logique ouais ENF la
logique la logique je sais pas
franchement je on va pas rentrer parce
qu'on va pas faire un débat sur les
transports mais non quand on se veut
populaire et à la portée de tout le
monde on fait pas ça on fait pas des
calculs d'apothicaaire et surtout que
personne prend la responsabilité
officielle en disant oui c'est comme ça
c'est nous qui l'avons décidé tout le
monde se renvoie la balle ça c'est un
petit peu dommage et je rejoins ce que
disait Philippe c'est que on a
l'impression que plutôt que d'avoir de
l'engouement on a l'impression que plus
ça va plus ça noircit un peu le le le
tableau et ça c'est un petit peu dommage
alors espérons que dès janvier on
reprenne un petit peu d'étoiles dans les
yeux et et que la flamme soit ravivée à
fond parce que sinon je sais pas comment
ça va être la flamme olympique bien sûr
attention que la flamme olympique Pierre
Chevalier populaire succès pour le
peuple après maintenant Greg rappeler
Jeux Olympiques égal populaires
quasiment par définition oui parce qu'il
y aura il y aura quand même des
animations il y aura des choses autour
de jeux aviration reste à savoir quels
sont les les cibles principales quand on
voit quand on voit ce qui ce qui ce qui
va concerner la circulation qui a
rappelé qui a rappelé
jeens avec un Paris bouclé le prix le
prix global des transports le prix
global des billets le prix de
l'hébergement c'estd qu'en gros on a
l'impression aussi qu'on fait tout pour
soit inciter les Parisiens à louer leur
à louer le leurs appartements et leurs
logements et à partir et à partir de
Paris donc là par définition c'est plus
populaire puisqueon on fait fu on fait
fuir une partie de une partie de la
population ça s'adresse malgré tout à au
monde entier pour faire rayonner Paris
pour faire rayonner la France c'est la
capacité à à organiser des grands
événements la réente coupe du mond monde
de rugby là aussi prouvé et puis les les
les récents événements organisés par la
France euh mais derrière malgré
l'héritage il y a il restera cette cette
cet événement mondial qui n'est pas pour
tous pas pour toutes les bourses pas
pour tous les pas pour tous les toutes
les familles ou tous les ou toutes les
catégories donc là non pour l'instant ça
ne semble pas être déjà un un événement
et un succès populaire pour l'instant
c'est partiel autour de cette table je
voulais juste dire par rapport au
populaire on se dit on dit populaire
tant que c'est familial et quand on voit
le prix des le prix des pour pour pour
accéder je dis si tu as une famille de
quatre c'est c'est c'est c'est une ruine
mais il y avait des B à 24 € oui mais on
après son plus vite que
lesutresment justement qui a des places
pour les j là autour de cette table
Pierre Chevalier vous allez voir quoi
golf golf GOF évidemment euh oui que
golf pour l'instant oui orang
spons donc vous quelques placees
voilàésitez pas n'hésitez
pas
sponsorz avir des
ou plus de sport que ça en
fait encore mais je désespère
pas
peut-être on en reparlera normalement au
niveau de tv78 on a deux accrédit pour
pouvoir aller voir les épreuves de de CG
de 2024 voilà mais bon il y a une
nouvelle phase là de d'achat de billets
qui est qui est ouvert donc on pas de de
trouver je rappelle qu'on est presque au
niveau de Noël donc éventuellement un
cadeau un cadeau pour Grégory can
quelqu'un regarde cette émission ça pere
une B
une bonne idée de cadeau pour le bob SL
Bob SL voilà c'est ça sport quel sport
quel sport Grégory ah ou oui athlétisme
ouis athlétisme mais bon c'est c'est les
c'est les places les plus cheres
ce qu'il faut rappeler aussi c'est
chevalier sera bientôt le de la fin dans
les transports dans la candidature de
Paris il y avait la gratuité des
transports pour les porteurs de billet
ça a priori on l'a oublié c'est vrai ça
sera le de la fin chevalier on va finir
attention pas une citation dewood au
moins c'est une citation de Pier
chevalier alors attendez attendez c'est
déjà la fin de cette émission on va
terminer comme d'habitude d'habitude par
une citation aujourd'hui je vous propose
une citation de la superstar du golf
Tiger Woods qui est d'ailleurs revenu à
la compétition la semaine dernière mes
échecs m'ont fait me regarder d'une
manière que je n'avais jamais voulu
auparavant je vous laisse méditer sur
cette phrase à bientôt sur
[Musique]
tv78